Jason, just before we get started,...
...I wanted to let you know that the idea you came up with last week was very good...
...and I've given it to Alex to implement.
So, well done and thank you.
Serious?
That's brilliant.
So, now to today's performance appraisal...
...it's a lot more structured than the ones we've been doing monthly...
...with a lot more paperwork.
It will be fair to say there are no surprises here.
I've let you know regularly what you've been doing well...
...and also the areas in which you could improve.
Would you agree?
Absolutely.
You've lifted your performance a lot since last year...
...and you've done very well to achieve the goals that we set.
And another thing,...
...I wanted to let you know that I appreciate how you've kept me informed...
...how you've let me know both the good and the bad about how we've been doing.
Now, as you can see,...
...next to each category rating, I've written the evidence on which I base the rating.
Have a read and if there's anything you don't agree with, let me know either now or later.
Actually, there is something here in the written communications category.
You said you haven't seen much to support this.
What about that report I wrote a couple of months ago on improving customer relations?
Wouldn't that account for this?
Oh, was that you?
Yeah.
Oh, I completely forgot.
My apologies, I thought that was Alan.
And back then, I really didn't know who was who.
It was a fabulous report, and yes, it would change your performance rating.
My mistake completely, but thanks for bringing that to my attention.
It was a good example of assertive, nonaggressive communication.
It's a lot easier to work with people when they're calm and assertive.
Cool.